Obrador y boluarte dos rostros de una
alianza comercial cuya fragilidad ha
quedado expuesta desde que el presidente
mexicano se negara la semana pasada a
entregar a Perú la presidencia pro
tempore de la alianza del Pacífico las
relaciones entre Ciudad de México y Lima
han agudizado sus choques y estas
tensiones escalaron en la noche del
viernes he dispuesto el retiro
definitivo de nuestro embajador en los
Estados Unidos Mexicanos y de esta
manera las relaciones diplomáticas entre
el Perú y México
quedan formalmente a nivel de encargado
de negocios Obrador sostiene que
entregar la presidencia Pro temporia
Perú es legitimar un golpe de estado el
gobierno mexicano impulsó a finales del
año pasado la suspensión de la Cumbre de
la alianza del Pacífico prevista para
celebrarse en Ciudad de México por la
ausencia de Pedro Castillo el
expresidente peruano destituido por el
congreso Y actualmente detenido Obrador
ha sido un gran consorte de castillo
porque yo no quiero entregar
este a un gobierno
que considero espurio
conformada por México Colombia Perú y
chile y creada en 2011 la alianza del
Pacífico sigue a la espera de un nuevo
anfitrión para su próxima Cumbre siendo
su última reunión la celebrada en 2019